good morning Jane you know we we
continue to keep the uh the crew members
and the families and our thoughts as we
proceed with this search and rescue uh
while we're uh cognizant of the time uh
and and we've factored in a lot of data
and and information into this search uh
this is still an active uh search and
rescue at this point and we're using the
equipment that we have uh on the bottom
right now the remote operated vehicles
uh to expand our search capability and
then also to provide rescue capability
as well
what is the latest out there on the
water what are conditions like for your
teams out there
conditions for the search and rescue are
favorable right now uh and so we're
making the most of uh this uh weather
window and and the good conditions we
have aircraft uh so still fly uh
overhead looking for any uh indications
of the submersible on the surface uh and
then but our Focus right now is on that
subsea search with the new capability
that we've brought online we have remote
operated vehicles that are working along
uh the path line where the plan dive had
taken place for the Titan submersible
and we have the ability to both search
and rescue
you you mentioned the vehicles that you
have going under the water I think one
of those is called the curve 21 rescue
system and are you happy that this is is
the right is the right vehicle recovery
vehicle for the job is it kind of go all
the way to the floor
the the rovs we have two rovs that are
capable operating on the C4 and are
operating on the seafloor uh right now
uh both of them have uh camera
capability they have sonar capability
they have articulated arms that are
capable of attaching equipment attaching
a rescue line uh also uh moving uh any
uh obstructions that might be in the way
uh and most important they're on the the
sea floor now and so this is the
equipment that we need and we have World
leading experts in the unified command
that are advising us it was an
incredibly uh complex effort to get this
equipment uh on site when we started as
a unified command there wasn't a
response plan for this
we didn't have uh any pre-positioned
equipment uh for this and so we had to
start from scratch and bring together
the best available equipment that we
could get on team quickest and that
equipment is on on scene now working on
the seafloor and and we understand that
there's a French
um vessel the atal antique which also
has an ROV and a Canadian one that the
Horizon Arctic uh you've got commercial
teams out there as well but if you know
it's awful to say because as you say too
your hopes and your hearts just go out
to the families but given how long it
has been now is it is it too little too
late
uh this been an incredibly complex
effort and we've brought together uh the
world's leading experts and equipment to
this site and so uh we remain hopeful at
this point and we continue uh with the
search and rescue efforts and our focus
is on using the capability that we have
now on site to locate the people and the
submersible
there's a UK team as well Magellan who
are better or based here they've they've
offered to send out their system they
think it could be really effective but
we understand the U.S Coast Guard hasn't
taken them up on this offer is that is
that largely to do with how far away we
are and how quickly it would take for us
to get to you
so uh during uh the initial response we
received we're grateful for all of uh
the support and offers of assistance
we've mobilized to move the Magellan uh
gear insight and are on to uh the scene
and we're actively working uh that
Logistics uh plan uh right now but the
most important thing is is that we have
remote operated vehicles that are highly
capable that are operating on the sea
floor now that have sensors and the
ability to conduct a rescue in addition
we've brought medical team out to the
site with a hyperbaric chamber so our
Focus as a unified command is bringing
on this expertise and bring this
capability uh to the maximum extent to
affect a search and rescue and we're
going to continue that effort oh that's
really interesting so you're confirming
that you are in talks with Magellan and
that they are actually getting involved
in in the search but you know as you
point out you've actually already got
teams there on the ground as it is
that's correct
and I understand also that there's a
member of the British Navy who's also
involved in the search what what
expertise or help are they able to give
yeah we've been uh very fortunate to
have uh World leading experts uh from uh
also from several different Services uh
contribute to the search and so the
unified command is made up of both uh
Coast Guard U.S Navy Canadian Coast
Guard Canadian Armed Forces private
sector I have expertise from Woods Hole
Ocean graphic Institute and really
thrilled and uh pleased to have a UK
Submariner on site that is helping us to
understand uh this complex undersea
environment in this undersea search and
so I really appreciate the support from
UK submarine Force
of course Great Hopes were raised just
yesterday when it was reported of noises
being picked up by the the Sona buoys
that are out there in the water what do
you think caused those noises what's
your instinct so we've taken that
information uh and and shared it with uh
top leading experts from the U.S Navy uh
and the Canadian uh Navy uh and they're
working on the analysis of uh that
information their continuing work on the
analysis of that information uh their
initial reports is that there's a lot of
uh the the sounds that were generated uh
were from uh background ocean noise but
uh that you know they continue to
prosecute uh that analysis and continue
to look for all available information
there uh what's important uh to me uh
and what's important as a as the unified
command is that we've continued to
search in the areas where noise was
detected with the rovs that we had from
from the time in that detection so we're
not waiting for this analysis to take
action uh the inaction the analysis is
really helpful to our search and rescue
efforts but we're not waiting on it uh
we're moving uh we've moved uh the
remote operated vehicles uh that we've
had on site to those areas where where
noise was detected now of course a huge
International effort out there that you
guys are spearheading at the cost of
this rescue I mean it's not possible to
probably put a price on it at the moment
but
at what point do you say enough is
enough
um we this is beyond all hope how long
will this continue
there's a time and place for that
discussion uh right now we have this new
capability that's uh available on the
seafloor actively conducting uh the
search and rescue and so my focus right
now is and the focus of the unified
command is really on maximizing the use
of those assets that we have uh on scene
and so we will remain focused on the
search and rescue but consider continue
to take in all available information as
we plan out our future operations
who will make that call will it be you
that consists of United States Navy
Canadian Coast Guard Canadian Armed
Forces uh and The Operators and we've
been in uh regular uh we've been in in
frequent Communications uh with the
families and so as a unified command I
will continue to evaluate the data and
plan operations most importantly uh
we're going to talk with the families
and uh and advise them of where we are
uh in in the search and rescue
operations and so there'll be a time and
place for that decision uh that decision
will be taken uh after uh thorough
consultation with the families but we'll
continue to focus on the search and
rescue at this time yeah
yeah as you do that do you have mixed
feelings perhaps about the time the
economic cost the the safety of The
Rescuers the resources that are being
spent on on what a lot of analysts have
now looked at and said looked to be a
pretty foolhardy venture
so there's there's going to be a time
and place for uh thorough investigation
uh I I don't know what that looks like
right now uh the focus of the unified
command is on the search and rescue and
so we're going to continue to use all
those assets that we have on scene uh
and really uh focus on locating the
submersible and the people on board
do you think there needs to be a safety
review into these kind of vessels
potentially after after this is all over
Jane there there will be a thorough
investigation I'm I'm sure that I don't
know what that uh looks like uh right
now but uh the unified command I can
tell you we are focused on search and
rescue this is this is really the focus
uh for our unified efforts uh right now
and so we're going to continue to
prosecute the search and rescue case and
and that discussion can be had at a
later time